[Music]
greetings
from a non-dynamic island
which is now home to apple's dynamic
island yes this little area on the new
iphone 14 pros screen is called the the
dynamic island we've designed this new
space to be highly adaptive and that's
exactly how i like to think of this
space
rad island a private island off the
coast of the bronx
and no there are no rats as far as i can
tell i did see a creepily kind of
friendly crab
but i didn't paddle all the way out here
just to poke fun at apple's product name
the bird poop on the island is pretty
dynamic
an island is a perfect place though to
put the iphone 14 14 pro and pro max to
the test there is scenery to test the
cameras especially the 48 megapixel
camera on the pros there are islands to
explain why the dynamic island is more
than just a joke and real action to test
the new action mode
where'd my hat go
i was sitting on it okay time to test
some phones
let's start with the screens on these
devices the iphone 14 and the iphone 14
pro have 6.1 inch displays
the iphone 14 plus and the iphone 14 pro
max have 6.7 inch displays i don't have
the iphone plus here today because it
doesn't ship until october
on the surface it may seem like the
screens on the non-pros and the pros are
just the same but this year the story is
much
deeper like this water
the pro models have an always-on display
which means you can just glance down at
your phone to see the time and other
important info no need to tap it see
here it's off and now it's on to be fair
android phones like this two-year-old
pixel 5 have had this a long time
i like the feature a lot and haven't
noticed it taking too big of a hit on
the battery life apple says the
brightness on the pros has been
increased making it easier to see in
direct sunlight
but
is it raining it's raining
rain of course it's raining
to be fair i didn't notice much of a
difference in sunlight either
but the biggest difference is that the
pros have the dynamic island apple
shrunk down the notch area here which
holds the selfie camera and face id tech
into this pill-shaped area
or
island but what apple did with the
software is really clever it's actually
not too different from this island see
this island gets smaller and bigger
depending on the tide
presumably at low tide you'd have more
space for picnics or napping
[Music]
apples island does the same it expands
to show extra information for instance
swipe up when you're listening to a song
or podcast and it goes into the island
here
hold down on it and you can get to the
controls same happens with a timer set a
timer for five minutes
five minutes counting down
tap on the icon and you can open up the
full app
i really love it when you're on a phone
call you even get these little wave
forms here
i'm wondering if you'd sell the island
to me
i'm not really selling the island i want
to change the name to dynamic island
okay
it might be quite difficult to rename an
island it's been called red island for
over 100 years i take back my offer i
don't want to buy it
the whole thing feels far less gimmicky
than i expected and is really helpful
when you want to multitask and jump
between apps
next stop cameras
the iphone 14 models have two cameras a
main and an ultra wide the main has a
better sensor that can capture more
light we'll come back to that soon the
iphone 14 pro models have three cameras
an ultra wide a telephoto for getting a
closer shot and a main camera with a
whopping 48 megapixels there are two
places where you can see the benefit of
the 48 megapixels
first it allows for a new 2x zoom option
it's really a cropping on the 48
megapixel main camera
then there's the 3x option which is the
true telephoto camera second when you're
shooting in apple's more advanced pro
raw format you can take 48 megapixel
images it's really great for taking big
landscape shots like this just look at
all that detail in there and compare
these two cropped in shots the iphone 14
pro captures more detail now of course
outdoors iphone photography has been
great for a while now it's in low light
that apple promises some of the biggest
differences with these cameras including
the regular 14. in my low light tests
the main cameras on both the 14 and the
14 pros were better but i wouldn't say
so much better than the 13s
you really have to go back to an iphone
11 or 12 to see the improvements
all four of the iphone models have
action mode a new video recording
feature to stabilize your video you can
turn it on right in the camera app
action mode commence
i'm stuck
test one
rocking in the boat
action mode
you can't see much of a difference in
the canoe footage but on the motorboat
it's certainly more stable but also when
you enable it it pushes you to the ultra
wide camera on land footage with action
mode was also a bit better but again the
regular iphone video is already pretty
stable
and our final stop all the features i
cannot test
so say i didn't have any cellular
service out here and my canoe drifted
away i'd be able to use these phones
emergency sos via satellite feature
that is if it was november because
that's when it comes out these phones
have the ability to contact satellites
and send messages to emergency services
the phones also have car crash detection
which uses sensors to detect a severe
crash and then notify emergency services
canoe crashes not registered action mode
off so say you were stranded on a desert
island which of these iphone 14 models
should you bring usually i say that
depends on what you want and what you
need but this year between the new
screen stuff and the additional camera
improvements the pro models have way
more appeal than just one extra camera
on the back of course if the dynamic
island doesn't appeal to you you could
just spend some time out here
[Music]
hey siri
are you there
i'm here
it's just us now
i'm not sure i understand
all right i have so many series
you